seems like a little bit like more fun or
immature hey guys I'm Stephanie and
today I'm picking a date based on phone
just look at my potential suitors here
they are in their iPhone glory I don't
even have anything crazy on my phone but
I was still stressing this morning I was
like let me look let me look through my
photos my notes exact like a bunch of
nervous men you know I was ready for my
phone to be taken because I have nothing
hot I'm an open book ladies all right
let's go guys I would say like off the
bat we have definitely like four
distinct vibes here for my gaggle of
suitors this one is red that's a
statement he also has an LA Fitness fob
in there which is a vibe this one you
know maybe he works in tech it's very
you know sleek it has a random
astrological sticker which makes me
think he's very la I think I gravitate
to the most because it's like clean and
like sleek and like protective she's
stalling before she gets to here and
this one this is this is a type of
person he at the clop socket so he's
like with the time what's better than a
pop socket with a can condensation no
beer cans soda can
music a little bit like more fun or
immature
alright let's like dig deeper shall we
come let's have the booklet la yeah okay
Jeff I'm going to look through your
phone now it says create your
opportunities and it's a photo of the
Hollywood sign a patch of dirt and like
a blanket air mattress no but when I
moved out here I didn't have a job and I
stayed on the air mattress for seven
months
and house I make my dreams come true I
make my imma create my opportunity I'm
not la I'm from Indianapolis I'm not at
the back of his
he has something that says be patient be
prepared create your opportunity with
like a Lakers dude
Lakers dude it is a hundred percent
LeBron so I clearly like sports clearly
very into inspirational quotes which
like not gonna lie I am too right off
the bat we got bodyspace weed maps blaze
pizza Disney Plus well-rounded that's
what the weeds for seeing a lot of
sports related apps we're seeing a lot
of finance related apps so clearly this
is someone who like sports maybe works
in sports
notes okay teeth whitener fruit broccoli
juice applesauce applesauce you need
some snacks pebbles are a natural
we level so eager real Avalon don't you
want to see a sliced in its a second of
his name creator of content for PBC on
Fox and at Fox Sports so this feels like
he was drafting his Instagram bio like
in the Notes app so he before headed
correctly host of after shows for
afterbuzz TV and a mac and cheese
connoisseur i love mac and cheese huge
props for that we're gonna go to tags oh
crap
so it's a lot of like there are several
girls texting him not gonna lie so like
that's something a lot of people from
work this one says I'm probably gonna
lay low I'm smoking on my front porch
and watching guardian of the galaxy if
you want to join hurry up this this
fight is starting if you wanna watch it
seems like Jeff is clearly someone who
works in sports he's really connected to
his family's a ton of friends and he
definitely has like a very fun chill
laid-back can like fitness sports weed
oriented vibe he doesn't seem like the
most like artistic creative person that
someone who works in both entertainment
and comedy I tend to lean towards guys
that are a little more in the creative
field versus I don't know anything about
sports so that maybe like not ideal for
his lifestyle but I'm down to learn
that's really making me sound like a
pothead and she keeps bringing up the
weed alright here we go this person was
a droid so like strike one
okay okay so first impressions he has
like a note on his phone like right here
on the home screen it says untitled
trailer cut script review and like watch
these various things so like clearly
works in media so that's really cool and
that would be very much in line with
like what I do when you swipe to the
right there's just one app and it's
hinge so he's clearly on the hunt so
when I
down when you download a new that it
starts it in the new pace I don't really
like have X on my back screen I like
that a clean back screen we're about to
do notes I downloaded a hinge for video
and it popped up so it gave it its own
screen okay so this first X that he
opened is him like endorsing a
Republican candidate like very strongly
and calling him the Republican Obama I
don't know if this will work yeah that's
definitely a deal-breaker sorry what's
his name my friend me my friends are
like we had political strategy debates
Kanye is running for president
Kanye is positioning himself right now
to be like the Republican Obama so my
friend text me was like yo Kanye is
definitely really doing it and then he
sent me like a news article and it was a
news article with Fox and Friends having
like a full-length conversation but like
Kanye isn't that bad and I'm just like
this is like that was very fast that was
that wasn't conversation we have
spirited debate I will try to give him
the benefit of the doubt so we found his
notes there's a lot of things about like
spec scripts pilots it's just great
relationship with my daughter so perhaps
he has a daughter which like is exciting
he does have a thank you God know which
is very sweet I personally am not
religious like at all so that would be
kind of something new to navigate not
something I necessarily like relate to
right away getting strikes he also has a
lot of like different script ideas which
is closer it's definitely like a
creative type for sure I mean she gave
you creative but she ripped you apart
final thoughts Andrew you seem like a
great guy I don't think we're aligned
and liking mostly all of our values so I
don't think it would work out between us
but I wish you all the best
I'm sure you will find someone who
values everything you did I'm just gonna
see myself out of everything you know
she brings you over the calls
I feel like her loss she's not the only
one trying to be the only way I have the
bad he has a cute little kind of reminds
me like the Grateful Dead skeletons
cartoon under here which seems cool I
did wonder we would need that we should
talk about that background maybe I
changed my mind last moment he has a
variety of like BuzzFeed apps on there
like maybe he works for BuzzFeed who
knows he has an entire folder labeled
D&D which I imagine is like Dungeons and
Dragons right like that game they play
in stranger oh my god sorry I literally
just hit text and like the first thing
that comes up is him like sending the
flip off emoji he Sagan's something to
someone saying don't know if you're a
reddit fan but I saw a discussion about
XYZ so he clearly like he's involved in
the internet culture he likes to read
he's up to date that's all very great
news yeah yeah the text seemed pretty
general so far so good
you're winning so far it's literally
says joke for grandpa my wife walked in
on me masturbating to an optical
illusion I said honey it's not what it
looks like yeah it's a joke I was going
to send that to my grandfather
that's all play good ok I like that way
what you'd say oh that's really funny
and I'm not gonna judge you and I love
you as a stand-up I both appreciate that
and I'm a little bit unsure my biggest
secret bump bump bump on second thought
though nah
mmm he's toying with us does really
convenient no only two notes notes to
leave a lot to be desired but he clearly
likes to joke around with his grandpa
and is you know not willing to share
secrets so he's not as forthcoming as I
am in my notes
which are my diary deleted only two
notes I think Nate definitely removed
some scandalous things for this column
there it's suspiciously clean like that
pop socket though ranked the pop socket
okay
Brent's background here is like a pretty
hilarious animated little cartoony
picture here so that shows he's probably
fun brent has 20 missed calls I could
never handle that he's clearly someone
that doesn't answer his phone right off
the bat we have all the typical apps we
got the music apps we've got social
media we got maps it's all pretty
standard up to here so we have a guitar
tuning app perhaps he's musical oh wait
I have an explanation for the guitar
tuning app so I'm not musical I'm just
really bad at tuning my ukulele ukulele
you have he's talking to someone about
like sci-fi Prince he texted another
friend just I want food a poet he has a
note that says ideas hand socks we have
thoughts for our feet our hands are
naked all the time would you be thinking
of gloves okay
I'm rebranding gloves I can sell you
twice the gloves if I just call them a
daily thing he like opened up his notes
and was like I have an idea
hand side hand side these are like those
ideas you're like laying in bed and you
just wake up at like 3:30
I knew genius when I heard it guys going
to Guitar Center and playing the
instruments trying to get discovered
maybe these are like sketch ideas like
he's clearly creative and clearly coming
up with ideas for something so that is a
huge win in my book there is a note that
says do not delete oh it's all his
passwords let's not read that oh my god
he wants to watch 10 Things I Hate About
You
hugging emoji clearly he's trying to
brush up on his rom-com oh there's
another one that it's like a character
animator so maybe he works to animation
am i a detective or am i a detective
will Brent be the one with voice memos
ladies and gentlemen we have voice notes
one of them uh says Sara admitting an
animal collective isn't bad is that you
oh I'm sorry
there's one right below it says like
where is my nose right now it really has
like some deep thoughts really respected
bridge yeah Brent seems a like the most
aligned of all of them both like my
universe he clearly is into music and
watching movies who would have thought
this pop socket dude yeah I feel like I
can't go with phone number one because I
feel like he's so immersed in the sports
world that makes just our lives just
don't overlap enough yeah I feel like as
someone who is not very religious who
doesn't really follow his side of
politics I think again it's not that it
couldn't work but I just feel like it's
not quite the right match Nate I feel
like wasn't super forthcoming on his
phone which makes me think he's not like
super open people knowing that much
about him which means I get Brent pop
socket Brent you are the lucky winner
because you like movies you like music
you seem like you're liberal and it
seems like you were down so we know what
you're about so Brent
boy I thought that was gonna go way
different
judging by when she initially picked up
my phone and she said immature and I was
like boy wait
good to meet you maybe we should just
always exchange phones on the first date
yeah people just or not
look there or not because maybe you're
making snap judgments that are wrong
let's do your phone is not you yeah
Brent thank you
[Music]